So our gathering today actually has a name,
and that name is "Your Sins Are Forgiven."
You might feel this is rather abrupt —
our very first time meeting,
so why talk about your sins being forgiven?
Now, next to me here there's a picture,
there's an image beside me,
and that image, in fact,
comes from this book right here.
I don't know if you can see, here in my hand,
I'm holding this book right now.
And this book —
well, I doubt many people could read it,
because it's written in Nepali.
I bought it over in Kathmandu,
and so,
this here is an event from the Lord Jesus' life on earth.
We'll have a chance to talk about it a little later.
Just now, after you heard Killy,
and after you heard Sai-fai share,
I wonder if you envy the change in their lives.
It makes me think of this one verse in the Bible.
What does it say?
It is the One who girds us with strength,
and makes our way perfect;
He is God.
The God we come to know today isn't just a doctrine — He is a living Person.